[Música]
à noite
então quem aqui já ouviu a frase em
briga de marido e mulher ninguém mete a
colher
provavelmente o que já deve ter dito
também essa frase eu já disse essa frase
quando essa frase eu era mais nova eu
não tinha real compreensão do que ela
significava só sabia que não devia me
envolver na vida privada de ninguém sabe
quando boy da sua amiga não está sendo
nada legal com ela sabe quando seu
vizinho grita tanto com sua vizinha em
que você consegue escutar da sua casa
sabe quando seu pai tranca a porta do
quarto e faz com que sua mãe de uma na
sala
pronto não silva depois de crescida você
vai compreendendo melhores coisas do
mundo você vai traduzir desconstruir
discursos caído como o senso comum em
muda
eu mudei quando passei a entender que
estava por trás da frase em briga de
marido e mulher ninguém mete a colher é
oba era violência doméstica
eu passei a entender de uma forma muito
melhor quando eu compreendi o que
significava relacionamento abusivo
até me dei conta de que já tinha passado
por um ano me envergonho não um
relacionamento abusivo é mais danoso
para a mulher do que a gente pode pensar
imagine aqui para as mulheres que estão
nessa situação é mais perigoso está em
casa em seu mundo eo privado com pessoas
conhecidas do que está na rua se todos
aqui sabemos do risco que está na rua
logo qual continha simples a gente tem
resultado
o mundo é muito cruel com as mulheres
vamos parar para pensar as pessoas estão
mais preocupadas em saber por que as
mulheres estão em relacionamentos
abusivos do que saber por que os homens
estão abusando das mulheres sentem a
pressão até parece que a culpa é nossa
que está na relação tóxica e não não é
minha gente
aliás essa cena que tem uma maneira
chata de culpar a vítima por tudo que
ela faz sempre alguém chega pra mim fará
renata mas ela tá nessa relação é porque
ela gosta
gente quem é que gosta que ele sofreu
apanhar mulheres entre 16 e 24 anos são
as que mais sofrem abusos nos
relacionamentos porque geralmente elas
não sabe quem estão que estão em
relacionamentos abusivos
ela não sabe porque elas nunca tiveram
muitas experiências prévias para se
identificarem um o medo da igreja do
agressor
a pressão social o afastamento de
familiares e amigos sim porque o
agressor faz da vítima de todas as
pessoas próximas
faz com que ela continue naquela relação
é cima até porque você sabia que é mais
perigoso a mulher está fora do
relacionamento abusivo do que dentro do
que quando a relação acaba o agressor
ele não tem mais nada a perder e esses
são os casos do zelo a daniela perez
microlins y ou seja lembrando isso mas
para muita gente isso não basta
sempre chega alguém pra mim e fala a
renata mas ela apanhou levou o grito
alguma coisa ela fez para merecer esse é
o tipo de fala que culpa vítima pela
agressão sofrida
eu já ouvi relatos de mulheres que
falaram que essa foi a pergunta que o
policial fez na hora em que ela decidiu
fazer uma denúncia
o que a senhora fez para levar esse tapa
existe um ciclo o relacionamento abusivo
que são a série de ações comuns entre os
agressores
o abuso como a agressão verbal a
gritaria o xingamento é crise de ciúmes
proibições
nessa primeira fase a mulher já começa a
ter seu psicológico muito abalado
geralmente o agressor falar saber que me
agradecer por estar com você que só eu
te aguenta nem pela família te aguenta
de graças a deus que você tem a mim isso
em conta nós presenciamos por conta do
tamanho da roupa na cor do batom do modo
uma mulher fala às vezes essa mulher é
proibida de sair de casa ela dizer fica
trancada literalmente de chave dentro de
casa depois da primeira fase vem a
explosão da agressão física
e aí são os socos e chutes um dos
pontapés quebra-quebra empurrão é é
ameaça de morte
nessa hora a mulher tem certeza que só
no relacionamento abusivo porque as
marcas das agressões e com visíveis a
taxa cortada é o braço quebrado é o olho
roxo
nessa hora ela decidiu tomar atitude
mais firme
pede pra sair e diz que vai separar que
não aguenta mais isso e consequentemente
o agressor ele na terceira fase do ciclo
que é quando eles se arrependem
ele começa a dizer meu amor por favor me
desculpe óleo não queria ter feito isso
eu perdi a cabeça não sei o que foi que
eu fiz é porque eu te amo tanto que eu
bater em você é porque eu te amo tanto
que o tempo rei da escada
olhe prometo que vou por procurar um
psicólogo isso nunca mais volte a
acontecer porque se você se separar de
mim eu não sei do que seria capaz
essa é a famosa fase lua de mel onde
todas as juras de amor são ditas e
infelizmente acreditadas e perdoados
esse ciclo acontece uma vez depois
acontece de novo e de novo e de novo
ficando quase impossível mulher sair
sozinha dessa relação a cada ciclo do
abuso que ela passa mais fragilizado
imagens acredita de si mesmo ela fica e
é nessa hora que o poder da empatia deve
entrar em cena
quem é que já ouviu falar no médio
acolher nós somos uma rede colaborativa
que ajudam as mulheres a saírem ela
somente abusivos
o meter a colher é uma idealização minha
como as quatro amigas aline carol laíse
thaisa em uma das cinco que conheciam
antes ea gente nasceu em março deste ano
em um evento de startup ea gente tem
apenas uma idéia em comum criar uma
plataforma online que ajuda as mulheres
a saírem de relacionamentos abusivos
a gente tinha 54 horas para pensar numa
solução inovadora empreendedora e de
alto impacto exponencial
afinal a gente estava no evento de
tecnologia ea gente queria mostrar que
as gerações da tap também é feita por
mulheres
pra começar tudo a gente pensou e na
internet fazer uma pesquisa
e a gente fica para o condado que não
choco e ainda choca muito toda vez que
eu falo
a cada uma hora e meia uma mulher é
assassinada vítima da violência
doméstica no país
uma hora e meia a gente vocês têm noção
disso
apenas hoje 16 mulheres irão morrer
vítima da violência doméstica no país
o nosso segundo passo foi fazer pesquisa
de campo a gente foi primeiro na
delegacia da mulher que no dia só tenha
policiais homens atendendo a gente foi
também no centro de referência de apoio
à mulher em recife que no dia também
estava fechado para atendimento porque
era final de semana e vamos conversar
com as pessoas na rua a gente queria
saber de mais do que as pessoas tinham a
dizer pra gente e uma frase em comum
entre todas que a gente achou muito
interessante foi que elas falaram mais
ou menos assim eu ajudar em uma mulher
que tivesse um relacionamento abusivo
mesmo que eu não conhecesse nessa hora a
gente começou a ficar cheio idéia na
cabeça cheia de idéias e ideia ea gente
precisava validar todas essas idéias que
a gente estava tendo
e nada melhor do que uma rede social
para ver se vai gerar um burburinho
compartilha curto e tudo mais
e assim foi criamos uma conta no
facebook e em um final de semana a gente
já tinha mil seguidores da página
poucas horas antes do evento acabar ver
o nosso primeiro pedido de ajuda vbox
era uma mulher do paraná relatando que
tinha vivido um relacionamento abusivo e
que mesmo depois de tudo acabado ainda
precisava de ajuda para se recuperar dos
traumas que tenha sofrido logo depois
disso começou a chegar também outras
mulheres só que elas queriam ajudar
vinham a de recife vinham de curitiba e
outra do rio ea gente preparou um
formulário de cadastro no mundo pra elas
eu achei o que responder onde moravam
quando o contato delas e como elas
poderiam ajudar a gente separou três
categorias apoio emocional ajuda
jurídica e ajuda a licitação no mercado
de trabalho
essas categorias não vieram do nada
a gente ficou sabendo que o emocional
abalado
a falta de conhecimento sobre seus
direitos ea dependência financeira do
companheiro é o que mais faz as mulheres
ficarem relacionamentos abusivos
a idéia principal do meta é colher é
conectar mulheres que estão precisando
de ajuda com mulheres que querem ajudar
estimulando a empatia ea idéia de que
nenhuma mulher deve sofrer sozinho o que
acontece quando a gente conecta essas
mulheres vocês podem estar se
perguntando acontece no pará massa e uma
parada mágica
acontece a sonoridade é isso mesmo
a sonoridade é a união ea aliança entre
mulheres
baseada na empatia e companheirismo em
busca de alcançar objetivos em comum o
conceito de sonoridade está fortemente
presente no feminismo mas se a gente
traduzir podemos chamar de hashtag
juntos somos mais fortes hashtag nenhuma
- hashtag mexeu com o mesmo com todas as
hashtags vamos juntas
a finalidade é quando as mulheres se
coloco no lugar da outra compartilham o
mesmo sentimento deficientes e ajudarem
com certeza vai sair alguma coisa boa
não tem gente que diz neve shinari um
bocado de mulher junta não presta não
presta mesmo não que quando a gente se
junta a gente queima sutiã a gente volta
a gente coloca os pés para fora a gente
vira chefe de estado
a gente ganha prêmio nobel a gente virar
dono do próprio negócio a gente vir a
dona do próprio nariz
a gente fica com a peste a gente vir até
nome de lei maria da penha
nesse tempo de vida do meia colher a
gente ajudou maria maria conhecer a
nossa rede através de um programa
policial de tv que estava passando a
reportagem sobre a gente e é logo em
seguida veio falar com a gente por um
box havia dez anos que maria estava se
tentando se livrar das ameaças do seu ex
companheiro mas eu não acreditava mais
na denúncia
para ela a medida protetiva era apenas
um pedaço de papel que dizia que o ex
companheiro dela não poder se aproximar
dela e que na verdade nada nada daquilo
fazia sentido mesmo ele em outro
relacionamento e ela também em outra
vida contra o companheiro
maria não deixava de ser ameaçada por
ele e ela chegou até a gente dá para
dizer que estava precisando de uma
advogada orienta ela no processo ela que
já estava em trâmite na justiça ea gente
fez isso o connectu maria com a advogada
que estava cadastrada na nossa rede e
juntas elas conversaram guiar o processo
marcar a nova data da audiência e maria
recebeu todas as orientações de como
devia proceder dias depois chega maria
pra gente
a menina é porque agora sou eu
querem ajudar uma mulher gentil ti maria
que legal tá querendo ajudar quem era
então eu tô querendo ajudar a atual do
meu eis por que ele está fazendo com ela
tudo o que ele fazia comigo e como eu
sei o que ele é capaz
eu não quero deixá la sozinha nessa
situação entenderam a palavra sonoridade
até hoje muita colher já ajudou
diretamente mais de 50 mulheres em todo
o brasil com apenas nove meses de vida e
tudo isso de forma online e eu aqui
agora vou fazer apenas um pedido pra
vocês meta uma colher
se você é neutro em situação de justiça
você escolhe o lado do preço se você
reclama reclama reclama de um problema e
não faz nada para resolver esse problema
você é parte do problema uma vez que tem
uma frase que pra mim ela faz todo o
sentido a melhor forma de reclamar é
fazer três a cada cinco mulheres jovens
brasileiros vivem ou viveram um
relacionamento abusivo três a cada cinco
jovens mulheres brasileiras precisam de
vocês mulheres ajudem suas mães e suas
irmãs suas amigas a colega do trabalho a
vizinha àquela moça que você viu no bar
leva no grito namorado ajudem converse
apoie scouting metá colher ela precisa
mais do seu ouvido do que de uma solução
sua meta a colher pergunta o que ela
realmente deseja é fazer uma denúncia é
separar é continuar na relação não julga
diga apenas que ela não está sozinha
lembra do hashtag juntos somos mais
fortes
essa é a pura verdade e homens nós não
adiamos vocês afinal vocês são nossos
pais irmãos filhos colegas de trabalho
vizinho amigos paqueras
a gente sabe que uma
o nosso de cada dia faz de vocês vítimas
também tem que ser o pegador tem que ser
o macho tem que ser agressivo
tem que ser tudo isso que chato deve ser
todo dia provar que é homem nesse país
sendo assim vem com a gente vem para o
lado humanitário da força não
compartilha piadinha de cunho agressivo
no facebook não compartilha aquele vídeo
que o amigo mandou um momento de
intimidade com a ideli e agora está
rodando pelo a tap não há não passa a
mão na cabeça do seu amigo que está
sendo agressivo com a companheira dele
não ache que a mulher está do seu lado é
sua propriedade meta uma colher também e
gente pra finalizar
eu queria dizer que o tudo isso começa a
colher faz é por mim é pôr minhas
parceiras lindas maravilhosas que eu amo
demais jogar com elas é pela minha pela
minha mãe pela minha irmã pelas minhas
amigas é por vocês e pelas filhas de
vocês é por todas as mulheres do brasil
que eu faço questão eu tenho muito
orgulho de dizer que em briga de marido
e mulher a gente mete a colher sim
obrigada
[Aplausos]